[Música]
Brasil la tierra del carnaval la zamba
el fútbol y últimamente también del
petróleo en efecto queridos amigos de
visualpolitik Brasil no solo es la cuna
del Amazonas el pulmón del planeta sino
que también es uno de los grandes
productores de crudo de todo el mundo
además por supuesto del mayor productor
de América Latina de hecho Brasil
produjo en 2022 más del 4% de todo el
petróleo extraído en el planeta por eso
no te extrañar que se codee con
productores de oriente medio como kuwaii
tirano los emiratos árabes Unidos Claro
que Brasil No solo está constantemente
en Boca de los analistas por su cada vez
mayor posición petrolera sino que hace
menos de un año la mayor economía de
América Latina también copó todas las
portadas del mundo por esta noticia
elecciones presidenciales en Brasil Lula
derrota a bolsonaro por un estrecho
margen efectivamente Lula el que ha sido
considerado por muchos como la Rockstar
número uno de la izquierda
latinoamericana volvió al poder por un
estrechísimo margen en las elecciones
contra el ex presidente bolsonaro el
Aliado de Trump que tampoco pudo
reeditar su mandato
[Música]
y como muchos recordaréis esto también
fue lo que causó uno de los incidentes
más lamentables de la reciente historia
política de Brasil un montón de
ciudadanos descontentos con el resultado
tomar un ejemplo de Estados Unidos y
asaltaron el congreso en la capital
Brasilia no obstante no consiguieron más
que sufrir números de atenciones Y
algunos heridos Porque la realidad es
que Lula había ganado y en enero de 2023
asumió El Poder desde entonces Lula ha
puesto énfasis en medidas sociales y
sobre todo medios ambientales por eso
Muchos temen que con esta tercera
presidencia de Lula el fin del petróleo
brasileño puede haber llegado al fin y
al cabo ese es exactamente el camino
seguido por la Colombia de Gustavo Petro
el caso amigos es que todo esto pues ha
hecho que visualpolitik nos hagamos unas
cuantas preguntas Cómo se convirtió
Brasil en semejante potencia petrolífera
Qué papel jugó exactamente el oro negro
en las dos primeras presidencias de Lula
cambiará realmente Lula su posición
frente al petróleo para cumplir con la
agenda climática será Acaso este el
comienzo del fin de la Industria
petrolera Del Brasil hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas
arranquemos pero antes un te has parado
a pensar en lo que te estás perdiendo
por no usark lo primero de todo y más
importante es la seguridad en la red con
sursar tu actividad online está
fuertemente protegida cifrada y a salvo
de ojos curiosos además con Clint web te
despides de los anuncios y el malware y
tus emails te preguntarás Pues con sus
arca alerta entrarás al instante de si
alguien ha intentado filtrar tu
información pero un momento porque aún
hay más surfshark es la primera VPN
comercial con servidores en más de un
centenar de países vamos que es algo así
como un pasaporte global a golpe de clic
podrás acceder a cualquier contenido
bloqueado por ubicación Y si te preocupa
tener que elegir en Qué dispositivo
usarlo tranquilo con la misma cuenta
podrás proteger todos tus dispositivos
ya sea tu móvil tu tablet la tele o el
ordenador esto también hace que puedas
compartir la cuenta con tus amigos por
ejemplo así entre todos cada uno
pagaréis unos pocos céntimos al mes
además por ser parte de la comunidad
visualpolitik podrás disfrutar de tres
meses extra totalmente gratis usando el
código polytic de lujo y dicho esto
continuemos con Brasil
[Música]
un largo camino
cuánto creéis que tardó Brasil en
convertirse en una de las mayores
potencias petrolíferas de todo el mundo
seguro que muchos pensaréis que nada más
encontrar petróleo bueno que el dinero
comenzó a surgir como caído en el cielo
verdad pues queridos amigos la realidad
es que al igual que Roma el Brasil
petrolero tampoco se construyó en un día
el camino hasta convertirse en una de
las 10 mayores potencias productoras de
petróleo estuvo repleto de fracasos y
sobre todo fue largo muy largo más de un
siglo entero desde su primera
exploración
independizado en 1822 en Brasil no se
extrajeron los primeros barriles de
petróleo hasta
1892 con Eugenio Ferreira de Camargo
concretamente fueron dos barriles no
obstante con esta primera extracción el
estado brasileño se dio cuenta del
enorme potencial que albergaba su
subsuelo y a principios del siglo XX la
iniciativa pública se unió a la privada
en la búsqueda de yacimientos
petrolíferos comerciales en el año 1907
el gobierno brasileño creó el servicio
geológico y mineralógico de Brasil Que
perforó 60 pozos en busca de petróleo
aunque no tuvo mucho éxito sin embargo
en 1941 con la ayuda del recién creado
Consejo Nacional del petróleo Por fin se
estableció el primer pozo comercial en
los municipios de domjoao y agua grande
pero la producción del país seguía sin
ser abundante Brasil solo estaba
produciendo para finales de los años 40
2.700 barriles al día en una época en
que su demanda interna era de más de
170.000 barriles cada día por el proceso
de industrialización que estaba viviendo
el país
[Música]
no obstante esto iba a empezar a cambiar
con el nacimiento del que sin duda es el
gran protagonista petrolífero de Brasil
en 1953 el gobierno brasileño fundó una
empresa que daría formal monopolio del
Estado sobre la investigación
perforación el refinamiento y el
transporte de petróleo nació petróleo
brasileiro sa hoy conocida como Pedro
brass muchos ya sabréis que petrobras es
con mucha diferencia la empresa más
importante de todo Brasil pero sabíais
que se pasó sus primeros 15 años de
existencia siendo casi totalmente
improductiva Pues en efecto no fue hasta
1968 Cuando petrobras dio con su primer
descubrimiento el yacimiento de guarima
Aunque este se quedaría nada Comparado
con los dos yacimientos que descubrió
seis años después en la Cuenca de Campos
los yacimientos de garoupa y pargo ahora
bien creéis que ya está que con esto
Brasil se iba a convertir en la potencia
petrolífera que es hoy en día pues nada
más lejos de la realidad
para 1980 la producción brasileña solo
cubría el 17% de la demanda interna por
eso ese mismo año el gobierno de Joao
figueiredo se puso como meta lograr una
producción de 500.000 barriles al día
para 1985 con todo no fue hasta la
reforma constitucional de 1995 cuando el
sector del petróleo brasileño de verdad
comenzó a dar sus frutos esta reforma
abrió el sector a la competencia privada
levantó la restricciones de entrada al
capital extranjero Y aún más importante
acabó con el monopolio de petrobras que
pasó a ser una empresa semi pública
aunque con la mayoría de las acciones en
manos del estado
con este cambio la producción aumentó
hoy Brasil logró la tan Anna en el
adultos suficiencia petrolífera a
principios de los años 2000 sin embargo
había pasado más de un siglo desde
aquella primera pequeña extracción de
crudo en 1892 y lo cierto Es que Brasil
seguía sin encontrarse en el top 10 de
las grandes potencias petroleras Pero
eso eso queridos amigos es algo que
cambiaría con la llegada al poder de una
de las figuras más relevantes de la
política latinoamericana Llegó Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva
[Música]
Lula el suertudo
amigos amigas en la política muchas
veces no se trata de tener a los mejores
gestores para pasar la historia sino que
también se trata de tener suerte y desde
luego Lula en sus dos primeras
presidencias la tuvo vaya que si la tuvo
Y es que veréis el dirigente brasileño
que ganó sus primeras elecciones
presidenciales en 2002 logró que Brasil
viviera una época enorme Bonanza y no
tanto por una gestión impecable de la
economía sino sobre todo por diferentes
golpes de suerte el más importante pues
este mismo Brasil descubre el mayor
yacimiento de petróleo del país
efectivamente en 2007 se descubrió uno
de los yacimientos petrolíferos más
grandes de todo el mundo el yacimiento
con una reservas de unos 29.000 millones
de barriles de petróleo lo que por fin
de una vez por todas permitiría situar a
Brasil entre los 10 mayores productores
de crudo de todo el planeta por supuesto
Lula no era tonto y sabía perfectamente
lo que esto suponía por eso en 2010
aprobó leyes para que parte de los
beneficios de las empresas fueran a las
arcas públicas además también benefició
a petrobras por ejemplo fue con ella con
la que firmó un acuerdo por el que le
permitía explotar y producir hasta 5.000
millones de barriles de petróleo durante
40 años sin embargo su suerte ni
siquiera terminó ahí y es que pensadlo
bien Lula llegó al poder en un escenario
de cierta estabilidad su predecesor
Cardoso había logrado domar la inflación
y evitar una gran recesión pero lo más
importante de todo es que Lula también
llegó justo en medio del conocido como
superciclo de las materias primas una
época en el que los precios de las
materias primas pues estaban disparados
de hecho tras la llegada de Lula el
superávit comercial pasó de los 10.000
millones en 2002 a los 47 mil millones
en 2007 Y por supuesto en esto tuvo
mucho que ver el descubrimiento del
yacimiento petrolífero y los altos
precios de las materias primas así que
bueno digamos que no es de extrañar que
el país creciera una media del cuatro y
medio por ciento anual durante esos dos
primeras presidencias y la pregunta es
sabéis qué hizo con todo el dinero que
logró recaudar Pues en resumidas cuentas
expandir los programas sociales Lula se
lanzó a crear programas como bolsa
familia que daba una ayuda mensual a las
familias más pobres o hambre cero una
campaña que pretendía reducir el número
de personas que estaban pasando hambre y
la verdad siendo totalmente honestos es
que estos programas fueron un gran éxito
por ejemplo el porcentaje de población
brasileña en la pobreza cayó más de 15
puntos porcentuales entre 2001 y 2011
tanto por el programa de bolsa familia
del que se beneficiaron más de 12
millones de hogares como por el aumento
de la población empleada Qué pasó de
unos 77 millones de personas a más de 90
millones y no solo eso Lula también
comenzó a impulsar medidas para la
protección del medio ambiente
especialmente contra la deforestación
del Amazonas para que os hagáis una idea
el territorio deforestado anualmente
entre el año 2000 y el 2005 fue de
34.700 kilómetros cuadrados una
superficie casi equivalente a la de
Suiza de locos sin embargo desde el 2005
hasta el final de la presidencia de Lula
esta superficie se redujo hasta los
4.500 kilómetros cuadrados por año por
aquel entonces Lula estaba tremendamente
comprometido con la protección del
Amazonas sin embargo su lucha contra las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
que en gran medida son provocados por
hidrocarburos como el petróleo del gas
pues no era tan fuerte por qué pues por
una simple razón Lula es lo que se
conoce como un nacionalista petrolífero
y Qué significa esto Pues básicamente
que no concibe El Progreso de Brasil sin
el petróleo ahora 13 años después del
fin de su segunda presidencia Lula ha
vuelto al escenario político un
escenario político muy diferente al que
se encontró por aquel entonces por
ejemplo hoy la lucha por la reducción de
las emisiones es mucho más intensa que
os voy a contar El caso es que por eso
cabe preguntarse general Durante los
reclamos de la agenda climática en
detrimento de los intereses de Brasil
podríamos realmente estar ante el fin de
la Industria Del crudo brasileño Pues
bien veámoslo
[Música]
la decisión de Lula
amigos amigas la llegada de Lula de
nuevo al poder resultó un alivio para
buena parte de la comunidad
internacional que estaba muy preocupada
por la gestión medioambiental de
bolsonaro en Brasil hay que tener en
cuenta que este presidente cerró varias
agencias de protección de la naturaleza
como por ejemplo el Instituto chico
Méndez también redujo en un 93% el gasto
en políticas de mitigación del cambio
climático y la deforestación se cebó con
varias partes del país como cerrado la
sábana brasileña un lugar donde la
deforestación creció un 34% durante su
presidencia no obstante aunque muchos se
hayan alegrado de la vuelta de Lula Lo
cierto es que el escenario no le están
favorable como en su primer ciclo ahora
el congreso está dominado por los
bolsonaristas los efectos de la pandemia
se siguen sintiendo sobre todo con una
deuda que ya ha alcanzado el 88% del pib
los niveles de pobreza siguen rondando
el 30% y los tipos de interés están
atascados por encima del 13%, algo que
por cierto ha llevado a un
enfrentamiento abierto con el Banco
Central y por si todo esto fuera poco
las proyecciones de crecimiento del país
pues tampoco es que sean las mejores de
hecho se espera que Brasil vaya a crecer
más de medio punto por detrás que el
resto de toda América Latina y el Caribe
sin embargo contra todo pronóstico Lo
cierto es que la economía brasileña ha
dado una sorpresa fijaos la economía
brasileña mejora bajo Lula y desafía los
tipos del Banco Central el repunte de la
agricultura brasileña y la solidez del
mercado laboral han contribuido a unos
resultados mucho mejores de lo previsto
por los economistas a principios de 2023
[Música]
además durante estos primeros meses de
su nueva presidencia Lula ha impulsado
varias reformas que recuerdan a sus dos
primeras presidencias por ejemplo ha
reabierto el programa de bolsa familia
que cerró bolsonaro en 2021 y ha
restaurado el Consejo Nacional de la
seguridad alimentaria y en cuanto al
medio ambiente reabrió el fondo del
Amazonas firmó leyes para embargar
tierras deforestadas de manera ilegal y
volvió a abrir el programa bolsa verde
que da dinero a familias pobres que
viven en comunidades tradicionales y que
se encargan de proteger el medio
ambiente
en general estas medidas contribuyen a
que Brasil vuelva a posicionarse como un
referente en la lucha medioambiental sin
embargo la pregunta que muchos se hacen
es poderla estar dispuesto a emular a
Gustavo Petro dar un paso más y acabar
con el petróleo nacional pues queridos
amigos Lo cierto es que las
probabilidades de que Lula sacrifique la
industria petrolífera brasileña para
conseguir este objetivo son más bien
bajas por no decir inexistentes Lula
calificó de irreal la propuesta de
Gustavo Petro de suspender la producción
de petróleo el ex mandatario brasileño
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva aseguró que
en el mundo Aún es necesario el uso de
hidrocarburos Y puso como ejemplo la
situación de Alemania De hecho si Lula
ya logró que Brasil se situará entre los
días primeros productores mundiales de
crudo su objetivo ahora es convertirlo
Ni más ni menos que en el cuarto mayor
productor mundial por eso petrobras
espera aumentar la producción diaria de
barriles de 3 millones a 5 millones para
2030 y no solo eso el gigante petrolero
brasileño también está intentando
conseguir una licencia para poder
perforar en la Cuenca amazónica en un
área donde se estima que hay reservas de
hasta 30.000 millones de barriles de Y
dónde esta compañía está dispuesta a
invertir 6.000 millones de dólares
solamente en la exploración Durante los
próximos cinco años
[Música]
a esto además se le añade el hecho de
que Brasil ha aprobado entre 2022 y la
primera mitad de 2023 el mayor número de
proyectos petrolíferos y gasísticos tan
solo por detrás de Arabia saudí y Qatar
y esto pues no es extraño pensad que las
proyecciones indican que petrobras
llegará a proporcionarle al gobierno de
Brasil más de 200.000 millones de
dólares de ingresos en los próximos
cinco años 200 mil millones de dólares
con los que Lula cuenta para sacar
adelante sus políticas sociales así que
ya lo veis no parece que Brasil vaya ni
mucho menos a romper con su tradición
petrolera con Lula de hecho parece que
pasará exactamente todo lo contrario su
apuesta petrolera será más fuerte sí es
cierto el nuevo presidente ha recuperado
iniciativas para luchar contra factores
que contribuyen al cambio climático Como
por ejemplo la deforestación pero la
explotación petrolífera de Brasil parece
algo totalmente innegociable sobre todo
sirula quiere mantener su gasto social
desde luego el medio ambiente es una de
las prioridades de este presidente Pero
al final del día los petrolares siguen
imponiéndose en la escala de prioridades
sea como sea llegado hasta aquí la
pregunta es para ti crees que finalmente
Lula se atreverá a reducir el de la
industria petrolera de Brasil qué
posición pensabais que tenía este
presidente Lula o con Gustavo Petro como
siempre podéis dejarnos la respuesta en
los comentarios y recordad con el código
política acabado en K podréis disfrutar
de tres meses extra totalmente gratis
con subshark el link como siempre en la
descripción y por supuesto si este vídeo
se resuelto interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like y suscribiros a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho una vez más Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo hasta la próxima
[Música]